The rules of the classroom.
Make us safe and happy.
With the first little rule has to do with our voice.
If you have something to say, raise your hand and wait to speak.
That's the respectful way.
Well, the second little rule has to do with our feet.
How we get from here to there.
Walk in school, don't run or skip.
You might trip over a chair.
Well, the third little rule has to do with our hearts.
It's how we treat our friends.
Be nice.
Don't be a bully now.
Don't be mean to them.
Well, the fourth little rule has to do with our bodies.
Everything has its place.
Keep your hands and feet to yourself.
Don't touch your  neighbor's face.
Well, the fifth little rule has to do with our work when it comes to an end.
Clean up all the time.
Please don't leave a mess.
Well, the six little rule has to do with our eyes when a person talks in the school day.
Look at the speaker all the time.
Respect what they have to say.
The rules of the classroom.
Make us safe and happy.